so recently Kevin Feige the Grand Poobah
guy over at Marvel Studios made this
statement that he thought that Scarlet
Witch could have soloed Thanos by
herself and the more I like what I
usually read this article right I read
this morning when I initially read this
I was like well that's kind of
ridiculous like that's kind of silly
like scholar which can never solo solo
Thanos by yourself but then I started
thinking about it and I was like no she
actually could but only under certain
circumstances right like Scarlet Witch
by herself under any normal circumstance
probably not but Scarlet Witch
channeling the power of C'thun
definitely know what does this mean like
what does it what does it mean when I
say Scarlet Witch channeling the power
of c'thun ie the House of M version of
Scarlet Witch okay and really secret
Empire Scarlet Witch to you because
gathon had totally taken over her and
taken over her body at that point um
when it comes to that the character of
C'thun he's what's called an elder god
in Marvel Comics and the way this played
out comes from Thor anyone number 10
back in 1982 written by a guy named Mark
Grunwald and this was a story that
basically detailed the very early
origins of Earth in Marvel Comics now
why those stories always originated in
Thor I'm not entirely sure I mean Thor
was a story a series of stories that
were based around the nature of gods and
the fact that Gaea who is the sentience
of Earth was his biological mom I guess
they kind of used that to sort of segue
from one to the other
regardless of the circumstance that's
usually how it played out but what the
story told us is that way before the
first single-celled organism became the
first multi-celled organism and then we
started to see life as we know it today
the earth was inhabited by like five
elder dogs and they were created by
being named the Demiurge now the
Demiurge was kind of like this sentience
of Earth's biosphere right I mean that's
really kind of how Marvel describes it
and really just sort of leaves it at
that that's really the only description
that we get but essentially in the
higher in the in the rankings the
hierarchy of Elder Gods um demiurges at
the very very top kind of a father of
them all and Demiurge produced
set the the be known as set who's
actually a really really powerful demon
as well as Gaia who we talked about a
second ago and then Asha tour and then
kaatham
and c'thun was this this being that
basically started like coveting magical
energy by becoming basically what was
called what was considered like a dark
practicer of or a dark practition of
magic right so the the Earth's first
black magician more or less you know
using black magic and so the result was
that he started kind of grabbing power
unto him
now over the course of some meal one and
a half billion years basically all these
different elder gods that had kind of
grown outside of just the original four
or five that were made by Demiurge
basically started going insane and
becoming evil and corrupted by their
power now a lot of this was due to the
fact that cthe own spread his influence
around the world right and basically
sort of kind of building a dark army
under himself and so what ended up
happening is Gaia basically went to the
Demiurge and said give me a son that can
defeat all these dark demons and so the
result was that guy gave birth to a tomb
a tomb in turn started traveling around
the world and killing all these
different Elder Gods that it came across
and then eventually became dimma Gorge
and then just flew into the Sun I know
it's weird but his comics just go with
it basically to make this short a great
big God gave birth to a bunch of little
gods who became evil they were consumed
by a newborn God who flew into the Sun
that's basically the way this plays out
I know it's nineteen eighties promise
guys nobody said it had to make sense it
just had to work but the idea behind
this is that C'thun was one of the the
Elder Gods who basically survived who
has escaped and he took off to a
different dimension now he did have
these kind of anchors to like the main
Marvel Universe to earth that there
would kind of allow him to return not
not so far in terms of like full power
but like try to make his way back and
the idea was when Magneto's wife Magda
had to had become pregnant with
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch um that
Gaston had sense the power that the
Scarlet Witch had and believed like she
would be a vector by which he would come
back one day and that's ultimately
exactly what happened um during the
events of house of energy he's he's
never really seized control of her in
her totality outside of secret empire
which is to say like he full-on comes
back it's always hidden a little like
bits and pieces of him but because of
the nature of C'thun and because of how
powerful he is he channels what's called
chaos magic now chaos magic is a
debatable concept in Marvel for the
longest time it was something Marvel
kind of teased that and they were just
kind of like this is why Scarlet Witch
can do what she does because something
something something
chaos magic that and getting lessons
from Agatha Harkness who is an actual
witch in Marvel Comics
but getting these little lessons here
and there it was always kind of this
thing of there's an untapped power
within Scotland which that issue harness
is it that she'll go crazy and who knows
what'll happen after that and all that
really came to a head during the events
of Avengers disassembled and house of M
and the reason why was because these
were two stories that detailed the
Scarlet Witch losing her mind right so
the idea was a Scarlet Witch envisioned
had kids that it was a believe that they
had kids and Malla kind of wrote these
stories in a really weird finicky way
and it was Brian Michael Bendis trying
to clear everything up but essentially
what Bendis came along and said was that
they never actually had kids and said
least I'm pretty sure was Bendis who
wrote Avengers disassembled it may not
have been I may have been wrong I know
he wrote house of M I think he wrote
Avengers disassembled
but regardless whoever was writing it at
the time basically detailed this
scenario where it turned out that the
scarlet witch's kids never existed and
now we kind of knew that before because
there was a story that had been created
back in the day where it turned out that
there were the shards of like the demon
Mephisto who was just kind of toying
with quick or with with with Scarlet
Witch and vision but because of that she
believed the Avengers had kidnapped her
children and were holding them from her
and so she lost her mind she ended up
using her powers um there is a trash
dumpster or a trash truck outside the
house and hopefully you guys can't hear
that but she had used her powers to to
basically make Tony Stark look drunk in
front of the United Nations that tanked
the value of Stark at Stark Industries
which in turn took away from his ability
to fund the Avengers the avengers
disbanded she basically spawned this
gigantic rearm aaaaa above Avengers
mansion like Hawkeye died in the process
and I mean it was like this huge fleet
right like ships and ships and ships and
like soldiers all over the place and it
was pandemonium
ah but all that basically came to a head
when magneto showed up and essentially
said like you guys are screwed or I'm
gonna take her to Genosha which used to
be a mutant Haven until all 16 million
mutants were destroyed and and he
basically resided there and so he took
Scarlet Witch with him now after that
that goes in the house of M and you end
up learning that that Charles Xavier of
the x-men had gone over with magneto to
try to fix the mind of Scarlet Witch and
realize that couldn't be done and so the
result was that that Charles Xavier
called together the Avengers in the
x-men and said the only real option we
have here is to kill her because of the
kind of power she possesses and
channeling the power of cotone she's
gonna do something and it's gonna screw
everything up she could alter the entire
space-time continuum right because like
her probably
Hex's the ability to kind of bend things
to her favor more or less like the power
of luck was really her manipulating
reality on a really really small scale
and so once they all realized that they
said well it's only a matter of time
before she reads like distorts reality
on a huge scale and so they said well we
have to kill her it's the only way to
make it work and so with Quicksilver
overhearing that he raised his Scarlet
Witch and said they're gonna kill you
but you can fix everything you can make
everything okay thus we got the House of
M where she completely and totally
warped reality changed everything up and
the result was that she was a you know
mutants were like the highest class in
society basically everybody got their
subconscious wishes now eventually house
of them came to a close and I've got
that video series on my channel so
you're welcome to check it out a house
of them came to a close and not even dr.
strange was able to stop her right like
at the end of the day she said
everything back the way she was supposed
to but she said no more mutants at the
very end and then took away 98% of the
mutant powers population now are the
mean populations powers right and so
because of that when you look at Scarlet
Witch channeling the power of C'thun and
chaos magic and then you even go into
things
following that like what is it the
Children's Crusade you go into things
that that follow that and it's kind of
like here's how powerful the Scarlet
Witch truly is it really kind of boggles
the mind right because the ability to
distort reality to alter it and then set
it back is a power reserved for very few
and there's never really been an
instance where we've seen somebody alter
reality on that scale usually it's
somebody using something like the the
Infinity Gauntlet or like a cosmic cube
or something along those lines
there have been fights between
characters like the molecule man in the
Beyond or that kind of ship reality to
its core kind of like literally you
could fuel the the shockwaves of energy
emanating throughout the entirety of the
multiverse and that's really where you
saw the power of the Scarlet Witch
because what you ended up learning later
on down the line is not only does she
take away ninety eight percent of the
mutant populations powers in the main
Marvel Universe she did it across the
entire multiverse right so like the
whole multiverse was affected by the
power she possessed and that's why I say
that's you know with with her being able
to solo Thanos that's really the only
circumstance she could do it if she
which is so grossly overpowered because
Scarlet Witch is only ever really one or
the other either she's just a normal
hero who can do some things and fly you
know and manipulate some probability
here and there or she's just like
multiversal godly powerful you know
embattled
everything and screwing everything up
right there really is no in-between
there when it comes to record there
there is you know every once in a while
but for the most part it's usually one
extreme or the other now in recent years
it's just been one extreme it's been her
being you know not really at her weakest
point but a little stronger than you
would normally expect but that's
basically about it she hasn't really
been house of em level for a long long
time but again this is the circumstance
under which I say that that Kevin [ __ ] is
right you know Kevin Feige is correct in
saying Scarlet Witch could have defeated
Thanos by herself but only if she was
channeling chaos magic in that regard
only if she was channeling about that
level of power now you could make an
argument for her being able to
manipulate reality on in a localized
space by creating you know these hexes
and bending luck to her favor but it
only ever worked so far and with Thanos
basically totem being the the totality
of the Infinity Gauntlet to himself that
it probably would have countered that
right I probably would have offset that
now if we're talking about the in battle
of Avengers in game well then yeah
because Thanos didn't have the fully
assembled Infinity Gauntlet at that
point and so it never really would have
worked it would have just been Thanos
with his power facing off against crown
at which and she probably would have won
but again you know thought he's not
wrong here it's it's an interesting
arguments an interesting concept in
terms of who would win who would lose
and who's more powerful than who but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end I thought I
would kind of throw that out there it's
pretty interesting stuff but yeah
whatever in this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb for if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
[Music]